[Music]
Parliament committees have heard and
questioned ELISA Ferreira
Yanis lenarcik paolo gentiloni and Kadri
Simpson commissioners designate for
cohesion and reforms crisis management
economy and energy the cohesion and
reform portfolio has been proposed to
ELISA Ferreira from Portugal
she told the Regional Development
Committee that no region should be left
behind I truly believe in this portfolio
and I'm committed to making it work my
attachment to this policy is deeply
personal
I have lived it in every season of my
adult life after 12 years as an MEP the
former Minister for environment answered
questions on topics including defending
a strong budgets for cohesion policy and
how to fight climate change
Yanis Lennar church from slovenia has
been proposed as commissioner for crisis
management a career diplomat he's
currently slovenia's ambassador to the
EU he's worked at the UN and the
Organization for Security and
Cooperation in Europe mep x' asked how
he'd make sure that the delivery of
humanitarian aid would be driven by
values not politics and how the EU would
respond efficiently to crises in order
to strengthen its global role the EU
must upgrade these capacities to be able
to help more people in need swiftly and
efficiently paolo gentiloni is the
choice for the economy portfolio the
former Italian Prime Minister will have
the task of ensuring that economic
policy encourages sustainable growth and
offers the protection and stability
Europeans need today we all feel the
sense of urgency to act to protect our
climates
this will require initiatives on many
fronts sustainable inclusive growth is
the number one priority MEP has
questioned him on how he'll square the
circle of making growth sustainable how
he'll tackle tax havens and tax evasion
and about the European stability and
growth pact the Committee on industry
research and energy quizzed Kadri
Simpson on her plans for the energy
portfolio she's the former Estonian
Minister for Economic Affairs and
Infrastructure
I intend to mobilize energy policy at
the service of the climate neutral
objective by further developing an
integrated interconnected and properly
functioning single market MEP question
her on the 2015 X zero carbon targets
competition in the gas sector and her
plans to combat climate change the vote
in parliament to decide if the
commission as a whole is accepted or
rejected is scheduled for the 23rd of
October
[Music]